The bigger they are, the harder they fall.
Celebrity is a tough business all around,
and the pressures of fame and wealth can be
too much for some actors to handle.
While these are problems that most people
would envy, these actors might beg to differ.
They came close to derailing their careers,
but we're glad they were able to rebound back
into the spotlight.
Natalie Portman
Natalie Portman has never really left the
public eye, but she sees it differently.
She told New York Magazine, "I was in the
biggest-grossing movie of the decade, and
no director wanted to work with me," which
makes it sound like most of Hollywood agreed
with the hate that hardcore fans had for the
Star Wars prequels.
"I can't fight a war for you."
"Jar Jar Binks."
"Me sir, ya highness?"
"Yes.
I need your help."
But with the help of some friends in high
places, she bounced back in a series of roles
in movies like Cold Mountain, Garden State,
Closer, and Black Swan.
Now, Portman is once again considered one
of Hollywood's top actresses.
She appeared in the first two Thor movies,
and her role in Ex Machina director Alex Garland's
Annihilation suggests she still knows how
to pick a script.
Paul Reubens
You probably know him as Pee-Wee Herman, and
the scandal that derailed his career has been
a punchline for years.
In 1991, Paul Reubens was arrested for "indecent
exposure" inside an "adult theater"...because
apparently, most watch adult films for the
thrilling plots.
In the fallout from the incident, CBS stopped
airing reruns of Pee-wee's Playhouse, and
Reubens retreated from the public eye for
many years.
After years out of the limelight, Reubens
reclaimed his famous character, donning the
grey suit and red bow-tie once again for the
2016 Netflix film, Pee-Wee's Big Holiday.
Nearly 30 years after the character's last
major film, Big Top Pee-Wee, the new release
was positively embraced by fans and critics
alike.
Robert Downey, Jr.
He had promising beginnings in a number of
critically acclaimed big-budget films, not
to mention a stint on SNL.
But Robert Downey, Jr.'s sudden fame, mixed
with an undiagnosed bipolar disorder, resulted
in a number of drug and alcohol-related arrests
in the late '90s.
After cleaning up his act, Downey started
to roll out the hits, appearing in Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang, Gothika, A Scanner Darkly, and
Tropic Thunder.
He's most known for his ongoing lead roles
in Guy Ritchie's Sherlock Holmes series and
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe as Tony Stark,
also known as Iron Man.
Nothing like starring in a multi-billion dollar
franchise to pull you out of a little personal
slump, huh?
Mike Tyson
The terrifying Tyson didn't start his career
as an actor, but found a renaissance as one.
Known best as a boxing champion, Tyson's controversial
life has included multiple accusations of
violence against women, longtime drug and
alcohol abuse...
"But I knew when I was in that court, and
when I was gonna get that verdict, I knew
the verdict was gonna be guilty."
...and biting off a chunk of Evander Holyfield's
ear in their 1997 rematch.
After retreating from the public eye in shame,
Tyson found a new life by appearing in The
Hangover from 2009.
Since then, he got his own cartoon series,
Mike Tyson Mysteries.
Holyfield and Tyson appeared together in a
post-credits scene during the 2013 boxing
movie, Grudge Match.
You can also catch Tyson taking on martial
arts and action star Donnie Yen in Ip Man
3.
Drew Barrymore
Child actress Drew Barrymore's career was
almost over before it began.
After starring in the 1982 hit E.T.
at age seven, Barrymore became notorious for
abusing alcohol, marijuana and cocaine—by
her own admission, starting at the age of
eight.
Fortunately, thanks to rehab, and the unlikely
help of a family friend...
"I had to live with David Crosby for two months."
"Which is crazy because David had his own
problems."
"I know he's, he was an interesting character
in itself."
...Barrymore found sobriety and started her
wildly successful second act, starring in
movies like Scream, The Wedding Singer, and
Never Been Kissed.
Barrymore also focuses on her family and charity
work while appearing in ads as one of the
faces of CoverGirl.
But that doesn't mean she's slowing down in
terms of acting, despite the fact that she
only took four roles from 2009 to 2016.
Because if she could come back from being
a teenage addict and the trainwreck that was
Charlie's Angels: Full Throttle, she can come
back from anything.
Fred Willard
Comedian and actor Fred Willard's career was
marked by nothing but funny movies...until
his 2012 arrest for a "lewd act" in an adult
theater.
The arrest cost him his job hosting Market
Warriors, but Willard was quick to recover
after an honest interview on Late Night with
Jimmy Fallon in which he showcased his legendary
sense of humor:
"Jimmy!
What do you wanna talk about first?"
"Ya know, let me say this, it's the last time
I'm gonna listen to my wife when she says
why don't you go out and see a movie."
Since then, he's appeared in Anchorman 2:
The Legend Continues, Fifty Shades of Black,
and a handful of television roles, and most
likely discovered the joys of "private browsing
mode."
Mickey Rourke
Former boxer and semi-reluctant actor Mickey
Rourke enjoyed a successful career...until
he was arrested for spousal abuse in 1994
after assaulting his then-wife Carré Otis.
Oh yeah, and he was responsible for her getting
accidentally shot in the chest once, too.
Just a guess, but he probably didn't get the
World's Best Husband mug that Christmas.
As a result, Rourke almost gave up the spotlight
completely, returning to boxing, then to acting,
then to boxing again—Wait, is he boxing
in a kilt?
Anyway, he bounced back to acting for good
with a lead role in 2005's Sin City:
"Let's go."
This major return, which he attributes to
his manager and his dogs, led to Rourke appearing
in The Wrestler, Iron Man 2, and The Expendables.
Rob Lowe
In the age of Kardashians, it's hard to remember
that a sex tape could once ruin someone's
career...and Rob Lowe had one of the first.
Only a few years into his career, Lowe was
filmed with at least three different women,
one of whom was barely above legal age, sparking
a wave of media controversy when the tape
was made available for sale against his will.
Lowe quickly recovered, thanks to the apparent
indifference of Hollywood, and a willingness
to own up to the situation.
During the years since he rebounded from his
scandal, Lowe has appeared in dozens of movies,
including the Cameron Diaz and Jason Segel
movie, Sex Tape, which was a nice meta joke
in the form of stunt casting.
Even more impressive, his television resume
spans hundreds of episodes across dozens of
noteworthy shows, including the likes of The
West Wing, Parks and Recreation, Californication,
Moonbeam City, and The Grinder.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
actors you think we should've added to the
list...